[Music]
here's what I want to know like you guys
do some silly stuff on your show and
then the political landscape turned
ridiculous and were you like why are you
stealing our thunder that's a show unto
itself is it not it is crazy but
fortunately on our show we we haven't
identified party and what we haven't and
so as a result we can sort of make fun
of yes the show is gonna end are you
prepared for that
well am I prepared I'm as prepared as I
can be it felt like the right decision
to make
and I was i wrung my hands about it but
we have a whole other season to shoot
and I think that it feels right
story-wise it gives it a finality that
feels really strong as we broke story
this year you have a chance to win your
sixth I mean it's crazy 600 of
ridiculous they'll call your name and
everybody's like yeah of course I know
people are sick of me let's face it I'm
not disappointed I'm just saying like to
win six Emmys in a row is like unheard
of it's like I don't know a streak like
that right but it hasn't happened yet so
it may be it may be just as it was and
some other fine actress will be up there
so will
how much fun are you having with the
cast and what happens when you all that
last shot that last shot when you
finally have to shoot a last shot with
that crew that you come to know and love
so much it's my it's my my dear group of
deep friends I adore them but it's a
year away so I'm not thinking about it
can we think about this yes oh that's
from last night yeah yeah I I was going
to a party had to wear heels
but I'm not gonna wear the heels in the
car so I brought my flip-flops and any
wise woman should do the same isn't that
what every woman in the world should do
is bring their football of course wear
sneakers or something there's no reason
to wear high heels all day long crazy
right yeah what is the president which
Selina do that no no Selina would not
she's in she's in heels and physically
uncomfortable all the time their life is
uncomfortable yeah
[Music]